have you had a moment in your life where
you say I'm going to do this for the
rest of my life or or you've never
really had to have sort of this you know
moment where there's light beaming down
on you and you know you know what I'm
saying like is it just been something
you've gone from one film to the next or
has urban something where this like
voices come to you and said I've got to
do this for the rest of my life and you
were meant to do this no it's everyday I
wake up every day and I have a voice
telling me you have to do this for rest
of your life every day I wake up and
every night I go to sleep taking that
same thing is that your voice yeah yeah
is it because you've had other jobs
where you know like this is what I want
to do I want to be able to love what I
do even if it gets hard and there's
difficult people involved yeah you know
I've had other jobs of you know I've
done a lot of jobs I've done a lot of
jobs in film I think I've done pretty
work pretty much work every position on
a film set you can but there's something
about being in love with your craft that
you can never take away from yourself
and you can never deny so like there is
a tremendous amount of uncertainty being
a filmmaker you know my mentor Robert
Freddy he's made every film since tango
and cash - die hard - rocky you know
I'll call him and I'll be terrified and
I say Bobby you know I like on the edge
of my seat on doin my life I just want
to make movies and he says get with it
dude
I live with the same thing every day
right which is you don't know when your
next movies gonna come you don't know if
you're gonna be wildly successful you
don't know if your movies gonna be good
you know you kind of make each film like
it might be your last one
because you've got to love it like that
so I think you know I don't know I mean
I think that at any point in your career
kind of always faced with those that
reality and those challenges which is
like you don't just do it because it's
the only thing that's there it's the
only thing you want to do the only thing
you can do that's why I make movies I
think that's why great filmmakers make
movies is because they don't really have
another choice you know so how is that
for you to hear it from someone that has
so many great tight
under their belt so to speak that they
live with that same sort of anxiety it's
refreshing it's good you know it makes
me understand a little bit more that I
think that that's kind of the the world
that we've all you know it's like having
your own social contract with yourself
it's like signed a contract saying I'm
gonna live the life of being a filmmaker
were you trying your hardest to make
movies every day and there are no
guarantees you think that's what makes
it so enticing aside from like the
creative aspect and and seeing this
thing come together the fact that it's
not that guaranteed and then when it
does work its magic
yeah I think that is what's so enticing
about it there's a lot of moments of
magic in making a film there's that
moment to magic when you're writing your
script you've stared at the screen for
10 hours you can't figure out what you
want this character to say and you've
been typing words for hours and hours
and hours and typing in circles and
finally you crack it with just one line
of dialogue and then you're off you know
and it's the same moment where you're
working you're working and working and
then finally you get a little bit of
money and then you're off and you're
making a movie and then there's that
moment when you step on set and you set
up your lights and you're blocking your
scene with your actors and you see the
scene that where you want to shoot it
and it just flows and you just capture
this perfect scene and you could have
never shot lists it could never planed
it just happened
and that cinema that's making movies
you